all right we're switching gears big time  what's driving you crazy we got a viewer  with a big picture look at 100 mile an  hour drivers and  life in general so here's what michael  wrote the problem with speeding in  nevada is much like every problem in the  state dui driving violence drug alcohol  abuse they're all the result of choices  that we make and he writes the solution  is in changing the choice inside each  one of us we all know metro and nhv had  a lot on their plate already but if las  vegas magically changed its attitude one  day  started making the choice to not do  these things  imagine what that would look like amen  michael but how do we get this message  to people who don't hear it  buckle up drive carefully please put on  that phone something's driving you crazy  the email address traffic 8 8newsnow.com